Nous sommes dans les années 1660,
sous le règne de Louis XIV.
Une nouvelle construction est
au centre de toutes les attentions.
Le château de Versailles.
C'est un chantier hors norme.
Des sommes considérables
qui ont été dépensées.
Versailles, c'est 1400 fontaines,
c'est délirant.
Il faut bien dire que personne
ne peut rivaliser avec Versailles,
et ça, c'est très clair
pour tout le monde.
Pour tout le monde, sauf un.
Le nouveau propriétaire du château de
Chantilly, il s'appelle le Grand Condé.
C'est le cousin du roi
et son plus grand rival.
Il avait dépensé une grande partie
de sa fortune en combattant le roi,
parce qu'il voulait devenir
le roi et ça n'a pas marché.
À la fin, il a été puni
et enfermé dans son château.
Que va-t-il faire ?
Il va se lancer dans une bataille.
Cette bataille contre le Roi-Soleil,
le prince déchu ne va pas la mener
sur l'architecture du château,
mais sur un autre aspect.
Il s'est concentré sur l'autre sujet
à la mode à cette époque,
c'était justement les jardins,
le jardin à la française est inventé.
Tous les nobles de France veulent
créer des jardins à la française,
qui sont très à la mode comme symbole
de leur puissance et de leur richesse.
Et le Grand Condé veut montrer qu'il est
aussi puissant que le roi à Versailles.
Le projet est extrêmement ambitieux.
Chantilly étant toujours entourée
d'une gigantesque zone marécageuse.
À l'époque, une seule personne semble
en mesure de relever pareil défi.
Son nom ? André le Nôtre.
Un architecte et un paysagiste de génie.
C'est déjà un jardinier bien installé.
Il a une quarantaine d'années,
sa réputation est faite,
avec Fontainebleau, les Tuileries...
C'est quelqu'un qui est à un âge mûr,
qui a des connaissances,
à la fois architecturales,
de mathématiques.
C'est le premier
grand paysagiste de l'histoire.
Mais problème,
quand le Grand Condé le contacte,
André Le Nôtre est déjà pris
sur un autre projet d'envergure.
Louis XIV le choisit pour aménager
les jardins de Versailles.
Je pense que pour le Nôtre,
quitter Versailles n'était pas évident.
Il était attaché au domaine royal et tous
les autres étaient des domaines secondaires.
Chantilly n'est pas un domaine
comme les autres.
Ici se trouve un élément rare et longtemps
considéré comme une faiblesse,
une rivière.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a en grande richesse ?
On le voit en arrivant, c'est l'eau.
C'est génial,
à Versailles, il n'y en a pas.
Mais encore faut-il savoir la maîtriser.
André Le Nôtre donne son accord.
Il accepte de mener
de front les deux chantiers.
Il ne le sait pas encore,
mais il va réussir à Chantilly,
des prouesses techniques qui vont
dépasser celles du château de Versailles.
En 1662, les travaux sont lancés.
Premier objectif,
assainir la zone marécageuse.
Pour arriver à assécher
ce genre de terrain, il faut drainer.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut essayer de faire
arriver toutes les eaux sur un canal central.
La zone à drainer est considérable.
Presque 7000 hectares,
autant que Paris intramuros.
Le Nôtre imagine alors un canal
aux dimensions gigantesques,
60 mètres de large
sur 2500 mètres de long,
autant qu'une piste
d'atterrissage d'avion de ligne.
Le but ? Assécher les marécages.
Les travaux de terrassement et de percement
des canaux vont être colossaux,
dans les documents d'archives,
on trouve régulièrement mention,
d'équipes de 200 ouvriers
qui doivent creuser, percer,
évacuer la terre pour
donner naissance à ces canaux.
150 000 mètres cubes
de terre sont décaissés.
De quoi remplir plus
de 5700 semi-remorques.
Le Grand Canal a été un effort énorme pour
les équipes qui ont dû travailler ici.
Les ouvriers vont rencontrer
un autre problème.
En creusant dans le sol, la nappe phréatique
qui est peu profonde à Chantilly remonte,
ce qui rend le drainage impossible.
André Le Nôtre va devoir
étanchéifier le fond de son grand canal.
Il avait une connaissance
hydraulique très pointue du site,
et il a pu créer des canaux
qu'il a recouvert d'argile,
afin d'isoler le fond de son canal,
et d'éviter que les eaux de la nappe
remontent et remplissent ces canaux.
À ce moment-là, le fond de son canal étant
bien isolé, sur les berges de son canal,
on pouvait drainer
les eaux des zones humides.